hi I'm Steve Smith um research professor
the question I'm going to discuss today
is how can mark transportation help
Pittsburgh to use less fuel I'm going to
focus specifically on traffic congestion
a problem I've been working on for the
last couple years because of the simple
fact that traffic congestion
particularly in urban areas increases
fuel consumption and so if we could do
something about traffic congestion then
we can certainly make an impact on
consuming fuel I've put a couple of
statistics hear that from the I guess
the 2011 annual mobility report that in
Pittsburgh annual per capita cost of
congestion to commuters in terms of lost
time and added fuel causes is about
eight hundred dollars if I look at that
nationwide over 440 urban centers I see
that the product the cost of in terms of
added fuel are over 100 1 billion
dollars so another stat that that's
interesting about traffic congestion
particularly in urban areas is that
forty percent of the time that people
are vehicles spend on surface streets in
urban settings are typically spent
idling so how can we improve traffic
congestion whether a couple different
ways one is that we could increase the
road capacity in an area unfortunately
in Pittsburgh as in many urban areas
it's not really possible to build out
build more capacity Road capacity its
geographic constraints in Pittsburgh
there's also you know land is being used
and it's hard to claim it so so the
other the other approach then is to make
reduce congestion by making traffic flow
more directly or more smoothly and
that's what I'm going to talk about so
I'm going to argue to that smarter
smarter traffic signals my slant on
smart transportation I can help here
it's generally recognized that
traffic signal control improvements
really provide you with the biggest
possible payoff for reducing congestion
on certain surface streets and of the
kinds of approaches you can take the
traffic signal control probably the one
that shows the most promise generally
believe this hold the most promise or
what are called adaptive traffic signal
control systems they're not in wide use
yet but adaptive traffic control systems
are distinguished by the fact that they
actually sense the traffic in front of
the intersection and somehow respond
adjusting the green periods at the
intersections based on what what the
traffic flows are presented in front of
them there are some examples of adaptive
traffic signal control systems being
piloted in the US principally in
arterial situations settings where you
have a single main road and you're using
the adaptive control to sort of manage
flows off of side streets on to this
main artery for the past couple years
I've been with funding out in traffic 21
a research initiative here at CMU been
focusing on looking at the problem of
adaptive traffic signal control in the
more complex setting of urban road
networks specifically focusing on
downtown Pittsburgh my group his as the
goal of this work is really real-time
optimization of traffic flows in urban
road networks urban road networks grids
you can think of it present a greater
challenge than arterial kind of settings
in a couple respects one is that instead
of just having a single dominant flow
there are typically multiple typically
competing flows that have to be managed
which which evolve and change over time
the other challenge that we're
interested in is true real-time control
if i look at the adaptive control
systems that are
they're commercially many of them
operate on a less than real-time
timescale they you know sort of pull
information maybe into a back a back
central reasoning location and then
adjust the lights on the order of every
5 10 15 minutes we're really looking at
real time real time adjustment of the
signals to to cope with with even
discontinuous kinds of shifts like
traffic accidents or the ends of
sporting or cultural event where garages
are emptying those kinds of things our
technical approach has really focus it
has to sort of key ideas one is we start
from the assumption of decentralized
control we are approached in our
approach each intersection controls
itself the watch is a traffic in front
of it controls itself and then in
real-time decides how to divide up the
green time between the different phases
of the intersection to to allow to a lot
of traffic to move through most smoothly
but even though each intersection is
operating independently they do
coordinate their actions by exchange by
simply exchanging information so so once
once the intersection builds a its
schedule that gets communicated to
neighboring intersections and then that
information can get incorporated
essentially providing a larger horizon
which allows it allows the creation of
green corridors if the dominant traffic
flow warrants that over the course of
the project we spent we've made some
interesting progress in 2010-11 we spent
developing the core approach and
demonstrating its effectiveness and
simulation on a downtown road network
using infants and traffic counts
provided by the city of Pittsburgh we're
able to produce some very favorable
compares
to the existing traffic control plans
that are enforced down down in the
Triangle area Pittsburgh over the last
year we've been focusing on carrying out
a pilot implementation of our system and
a pilot test in the East Liberty region
of Pittsburgh you know so spend the rest
of the time kind of summarizing that so
here's a picture of the the pilot
implementation site it's a it's an area
of East Liberty that surrounds the
essentially a new target department
store that is entered into the was
created was built last about a year and
a half ago what is nice about this this
particular site here's the target is is
that these blue circled intersections
all as part of the redevelopment of an
introduction of the target department
store these intersections were rebuilt
and outfitted with with camera detection
so it's a great low-cost way of us
trying to test out our adaptive system
we consulted with the city and actually
the city suggested that we add in this
ninth intersection and and which would
it create a more of a grid pattern which
and a more challenging environment for
us to try out on so with that we were
able to obtain funding from the Heinz
endowments through their breathe
initiative basically motivated by the
idea of reducing emissions and air
pollutants in the air by improving
traffic flow and and this is the the
test side we came up with so so let's
see if i can find the cursor here there
so the really three dominant flows
through this area there's this one
there's Penn Avenue cutting through Penn
circle and then there's also this third
flow moving back and forth this way so a
challenging of that environment so
here's a just a concept of operations of
the basic system that we built to
put into that thing so the basic idea is
let's see we use the cameras we're
taking real-time video feeds from the
cameras those are extracted and pushed
into the the shirt rack system of a
processor that's running our strategy
then this system for each intersection
will compute a schedule that essentially
optimizes the movement of all the
vehicles that it sees currently through
the intersection so sort of minimize
dead time and then based on that
schedule it'll send commands to the
actual controller the piece of hardware
that actually runs the traffic light and
enforces the safety constraints once
that schedule is built it's also then
communicated to downstream neighbors and
then that gives the that indicates
what's coming down the pike to that
intersection and as its building its
plan it can use it has a now extended
horizon that it can use to do its
planning and then the whole process gets
repeated every few seconds so it's very
real time we're running recomputing the
plan detecting new traffic and
reconnecting every couple seconds so
here's a here's a short video of the of
the system in action sort of on the
before on the left hand side is the
situation before we installed the
pre-existing control and then on the
right hand side is the same intersection
this is the main intersection in the
pilot site the pen and pencil
intersection so this this video is sped
up to about eight times so we can see
the more the aggregate flows moving
through but if you look closely I think
you'll you'll agree that that you've got
a higher volumes on the left so these
are taken at the same time of day so
it's really the improved flow we did a
controlled study of the
of the system by performing a series of
before and after run-throughs of or
drive-throughs along each of twelve
different routes through this pilot site
we kind of picked the twelve highest
volume routes and growth drove them
multiple times or over across multiple
days for each of four different periods
of the day the a.m rush period the mid
day period the PM rush and the evening
and as we do these driving we did we
carried a GPS tracking device that
essentially recorded our speed our
travel times and the number stops we
made the amount of time we were all
sitting idle at lights etc and then we
process that information we did that
both with the pre-existing control plans
that were in place at the intersection
and then after we installed our system
we ran them again to do a comparative
kinds of a kind of analysis one thing we
did in aggregating the data we use the
traffic volume data to combine the data
along different routes so we get a
pretty bow mean so as you can see from
the statistics on this slide the the
adaptive system actually had a quite a
significant impact on the on several
sort of common metrics ranging from sort
of an average reduction in traveling
travel time of 25% an average increase
in speed of thirty-four percent number
of stops reduced by thirty one percent
and the wait time reduced by forty
percent so all that sort of translates
down off I want to look at fuel
consumption we get an average reduction
in fuel consumption of of 21 and a half
percent so a fairly significant both in
terms of improving the efficiency of the
process and also improving the
the fuel consumption and release of
emissions into the into the air so what
are our current plans well we have plans
too we are currently planning to expand
the pilot test and we sort of looking in
two directions right now in the fall we
hope to push eastward toward bakery
square and Fifth Avenue that's the the
diagram and the upper right there this
is actually a fairly low cost extension
the green intersections in that little
map there already have camera detection
that I think we're put in place with the
renovation of bakery square so and then
in a second phase we'd like to expand
west along the bomb and center court or
so that's the map in the bottom right
corner there in 2013 the city has funds
to and and they are planning to upgrade
22 intersections along those two
corridors to have new controllers and
and fiber-optic cable that provides a
communication infrastructure so that
would be a that again would be a great
infrastructure to build on it would get
us part of the way we'd have to we'd
have to buy the cameras but we get that
the vision the interesting vision is if
if we expand in both these directions
the West Corridor hooks up to craig
street and Bigelow and so in essence you
we have created a virtual corridor from
the East End downtown and potentially
providing a an alternative to some of
the Parkway East traffic so this is kind
of part of the vision if we in fact were
to extend all 600 intersections in the
city of Pittsburgh we would reduce fuel
consumption annually by 4.3 million
gallons there's a lot to be gained by
doing us
smarter job of managing traffic lights